welcome to Hardy's hobbies the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and delve into newest technical parts
today we're taking a look at why the GTX
1080 Ti is quite stupid because of how
overpriced it is and how the GTX 1180 is
the future but before we delve into that
make sure to hit the subscribe button if
you guys would like to stay updated with
latest tech news relate to pcs and
gaming so what's so bad about the gtx
980ti
the performance is stellar right well
that is true
but the only problem is its price right
now the lowest price that you can buy
the GTX 1080 Ti is a whopping 850
dollars which is $150 over MSRP now this
is a lot better than before when it
costed like 1,100 $1,200 but this is
still an outrageous price and doesn't
really make sense to buy right now and
on top of this the 10th series is about
to be outdated very soon so it doesn't
really make sense to buy an almost
Octavia card in over price when a
serious is about to go outdated you
would actually expect to be able to buy
the card for under price and really good
deals and because of that it really
doesn't make sense to buy a gtx 980ti
right now given the current price
situation and the proximity to the next
generation of GPUs I'm in video but how
exactly is the gtx 1180 going to perform
in the first place well there was a
rumour a couple of weeks ago now this is
just a rumor
so make sure to keep that in mind but
what this rumour is suggesting is that
the gtx 1180 is going to perform very
similarly to the gtx 1080i so here's the
specs that the rumor is suggesting first
of all it's going to go from the Pascal
architecture to turning architecture and
it's process it's going to change from
the 60 nanometer process found on the
GTX to 1080 Ti and all the other 10
serious cards to the tall nanometer
process on top of this the die size is
actually an increase from 314
millimeters squared on the GTX 1082
400 millimeters squared but this die
size increase is more than worth it for
sure as for CUDA cores the GTX 1080 has
2560 cuda cores and this new gtx 1180 is
supposed to have 3000
eighty-four CUDA course which is
identical to the CUDA cores of the gtx
980ti
so in that standpoint the GTX lemony is
pretty much identical in performance
with deep gtx 980ti the gtx 1080 has 8.7
teraflops of performance the gtx 1080i
has 11.3 teraflops
but the gtx 1180 I suppose a 13th or
teraflops of performance also there is
supposed to be a huge upgrade of memory
because of the utilization of the new
GDR 6 memory on the gtx 980ti there is
11 gigabytes of gddr5 X memory on this
new GTX 980 there supposed to be
anywhere from 8 to 16 gigabytes of
memory but this is GTD r6 memory so the
performance should be exponentially
better the memory speed is going to go
from 11 gigabits per second on the gtx
980ti
to 16 Givet per second on the new wood
1180 finally as for memory bandwidth the
gtx 1080i has four hundred and eighty
four gigabytes per second and this new
gtx 1180 s boys have 512 gigabytes per
second and on top of all this the power
consumption is much better the gtx 980ti
is TDP is 250 watts but the TDP of the
gtx 1180 is anywhere from 170 watts to
200 watts so as you guys can see it's
more efficient and more powerful overall
the new gtx 1180
matches or exceeds these gtx 1080i in
almost all specs and on top of that has
better power consumption GDD are six
memory and a newer process and as a
result the gtx lemme ad should in theory
performed better than the gtx
ten atti so what real-world performance
this is exactly convert to well this
would be very similar to the performance
of the gtx 980ti so pretty much all
current games at 60 frames per second at
4k in most games actually at 70 or 80
frames per second and on top of that it
should kill triple monitor 1080p gaming
and q HD ultra wide gaming so if you
guys are interested in any of those
and this may definitely be worth waiting
for but what about price well I thought
that price would be higher because of
the current cryptocurrency mining
situation and the RAM situation but
according to this leak the gtx 1180 is
only supposed to cost $700 which is the
same MSRP at the gtx 1080 came out 4 so
it's really good value to put that in
comparison the gtx 980ti cost $850 right
now and so this is a much better value
and so it's definitely worth waiting for
if this does come true furthermore after
the founders edition of the GTX 980 was
released for six hundred and ninety nine
dollars a couple months later the
third-party
variants of that card actually came out
for an MSRP of 599 dollars so we may see
a similar trend on the gtx 1180 so the
GTX levy ID from companies like MSI EVGA
gigabyte Asus might only cost five
hundred ninety nine dollars as opposed
to six hundred ninety nine dollars so
you guys may even be able to save more
money there but what about the RAM
pricing and the GPU cryptocurrency money
situation well first of all as for RAM
RAM prices have been going up for over a
year now but the NVIDIA GPUs have only
been going up since the beginning of
this year after the etherium boom so as
a result I don't really think ramped
affects the GPU price too much like for
example RAM prices were much worse than
what they are right now in a November
and December of last year but video GPUs
were actually still being offered for
MSRP or even lower in those months so as
a result I really don't think Ram price
has too big of an effect on the GPU
market and ask for a cryptocurrency
mining GPU mining is still definitely
profitable and viable but there's simply
not that huge hype around it and it's
not an easy way to make a money anymore
it's more of a long term process and as
a result there's much less demand from
GPU miners from gaming graphics cards
and does there's less demand from GPU
miners and so the prices should
you better therefore I really believe
that this pricing is quite reasonable
and expectable from Nvidia so what about
the release date though when is this new
GPU going to come out well obviously we
don't have any solid proof but actually
at GDC gamers Nexus was able to get in
contact with SK Hynix who is the memory
producer for immediate GPUs and they
told gamer Nexus that they're going to
be ramping up their production for GT
br6 memory in just three months now GTC
occurred at the end of March and so this
would suggest that SK Hynix is going to
start their GT dr6 memory production at
the end of June and if s K hynek's is
ramping up their production that
probably means that Nvidia is coming out
with their next generation of GPUs soon
after so I think we can expect these new
cards in the end of July or August so
pretty much in the mid to end of summer
this is actually what an article and
Tom's Hardware and the rumors suggest so
this is probably what's happening and
Plus Nvidia is known for their two to
three-year cycles so it does coincide
with the past as well so should you wait
well in my opinion I definitely think
that you guys should wait I think the
only reason that you guys should avoid
is if there is a crazy deal on the GTX
10 ATT I'd like for $600 but I don't
really see that happening in the
imminent future so I think our best bet
is just to wait for the gtx 1180 also
you guys to keep in mind that even if
the gtx 1180 isn't as good as what these
rumors suggest once the gtx 1180 comes
out the 10 series graphics cards would
become outdated and as a result the gtx
1080i would further drop in price so
even if the gtx 1180 doesn't perform as
well as it is being suggested by this
rumor it's still definitely worth
waiting because the gtx 1080i would drop
in price once the gtx 1180 and 1170 and
all those other cards come out and this
is not just true for the 1080 Ti is it
true for all 10 series cards once the
next 11 series cars come out so any of
you guys considering to buy any 10
series card right now-she consider
waiting just to save a bit of money or
even upgrading to the 11 series overall
the gtx 1080
provides awesome performance however it
is really overpriced right now and it
really doesn't make sense to buy it and
on top of this the GTX 1180 is coming
out very soon and it is rumored to have
pretty much identical performance but at
a much better price so you guys should
definitely consider waiting for the new
gtx 1180 before making any rash
decisions and you may regret it soon so
what do you guys think do you guys think
that the price situation for the gtx
980ti will get better or do you think
it's just better to wait for the gtx at
1180 make sure to post down below in the
comments what you guys think because I
do read all my comments and I'm curious
as to what you guys think so make sure
to post your thoughts also if you guys
liked this video then make sure drop a
like and make sure to hit that subscribe
button if you guys would like to see
more videos just like this every single
day but until next time bye
[Music]